brace yourself
if you're driving pull over if you're
standing up you are going to want to sit
down
we have shocking news
a drag queen performer and self-styled
lgbtq plus youth advisor has just been
caught with a bunch of child pornography
yes
yes according to the pennsylvania
attorney general's office it turns out
that a man who spends all of his time
thinking about deviant sex and little
kids
a man who puts on sexually charged
performances specifically for kids
turns out that guy
has a sexual interest in kids
can you believe it
the news comes as an especially tough
blow
to groups such as drag queen story hour
which keeps having the rotten luck of
repeatedly associating with child
rapists what are the odds it comes as a
shock to people who are so blinded by
their own ideology that they can't see
the plain reality right in front of
their face
and it comes as an important lesson to
everybody
if you play stupid games
you will win stupid prizes i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from jordan
elizabeth who says the next daily wire
merch should be a don't squish t-shirt i
totally agree we do not squish around
here folks not on the michael knowles
show this is a hard body only zone this
is a stiff area here no squishing
whatsoever this is getting a little a
little bit lurid here this is getting a
little titillating we'll move on but do
not squish whatever you do do not squish
okay we need to communicate
our ideas clearly when you want to
communicate clearly you've got to check
out peertalk right now go to
puretalk.com enter promo code knowles
podcast you are probably getting pinched
right now at the gas tank at the grocery
store whatever you are paying for the
price is going up with one exception if
you hear my call with one exception
that would be pure talk you can save a
ton of money on your cell phone pure
talk gives you talk text plenty of data
for 30 bucks a month
30 but no price increase there we're
talking about a major price decrease i
am a pure talk customer they have the
most reliable network in america the 5g
coverage is great they're veteran owned
they've got a customer service team
right here in the usa so you will be
able to understand them when you call
them stop giving your money away to
verizon at t and t-mobile switch over to
my guys over at puretalk they make it
super easy there is a no risk money back
guarantee go to puretalk.com select a
plan enter promo code knowles podcast to
save 50 an additional 50
off your first month switch over to
puretalk service in less than 10 minutes
that is promo code knowles podcast canon
wle s p o d c a s t all one word at
puretalk.com
if you play stupid games you will win
stupid prizes if you encourage
sexual deviants big hairy husky dudes
who put on skimpy little women's outfits
and stiletto heels and they have a real
strange interest in jiggling around for
little kids
i think probably you're gonna you're
gonna wind up with guys who have a
sexual interest in little kids that's
what's gonna happen it's not just on the
weird sex stuff that this rule holds
true it holds true ever there's a video
that was going viral yesterday it's
about a poor bodega worker jose alba
he's a 61 year old bodega worker
he was in new york i believe and he was
attacked by a career criminal the career
criminal's name is austin simon austin
simon this big hulking dude walks behind
toward this
somewhat elderly
bodega owner
goes behind the counter starts pushing
him around won't let him get up won't
let him move and then they get into a
scrap the the
big
career criminal guy's girlfriend
apparently stabs the bodega owner and
that or the bodega worker rather and
then the bodega worker stabs the big
hulking guy to death
we actually have the clip of this so we
have security camera footage which is
really really important because of how
corrupt our criminal justice system has
become
take a look at this if you're listening
right now i will narrate it for you you
see this big hulking dude wearing what
is apparently a very expensive t-shirt
and he pushes the bodega guy this older
guy
who's
smaller he's older
apparently they got into a fight because
this criminal's girlfriend didn't have
75 cents and so the bodega guy said well
you can't if you don't have the money
you can't buy the the product so this
guy goes behind the counter starts
pushing him around
really gets up in his face and the
bodega guy he's just he's just kind of
sitting there he's trying to get he's
trying to walk away but the criminal
won't let him get away the criminal
starts really beating him up now the
bodega guy starts bleeding
it's not good and then it now we're off
camera at this point apparently the
the girlfriend i guess had already
stabbed the bodega guy at this point
it's a little unclear because you're off
camera
next thing you know though
this what the criminal didn't count on
was the bodega guy grabs a knife and
stabs the criminal
so the criminal goes down
the bodega guy is bloodied but he's
holding a knife now and he's taken down
this thug
who was pushing him around and trying to
steal his stuff and not even letting him
retreat the bodega guy's trying to leave
he's he's trying to extricate himself
from the situation the criminal won't
let him do it guess who gets charged
with a crime
guess who get you know you know the
answer because of the state of our
of the state of our justice system so
there's a racial element here the
criminal is a black guy and the bodega
guy is hispanic i guess with a name like
jose alba
but hispanics are borderline white these
days and so you've got this racial
element at play
and then you've got what's even more at
play here in new york you've got a
preference for criminals and a a
disadvantage for victims
there's no way you can watch that video
and say that the bodega guy isn't is the
aggressor
there's no you can watch that video and
say that this criminal is the victim and
when i say criminal by the way this
guy's got a rap sheet a mile long this
guy was already out on parole for
assaulting a cop at the time of this
deadly encounter he has at the very
least eight prior arrests for assault
for robbery for assault during a
domestic dispute on and on those are
just the ones that we know about
and so what happens the poor bodega guy
who's defending himself gets arrested
and the manhattan district attorney
alvin bragg who is entirely pro-criminal
and anti-victim he's throwing him in the
can with a sky-high bail the the bail
for this bodega guy is a quarter million
dollars you think bodega guys have a
quarter million dollars lying around i
don't
and by the way the da wanted a higher
bail the d.a wanted a 500 000 bail
but the court lowered it to quarter
million dollars it won't matter there's
no way the bodega guy is going to pay it
there is nothing compassionate about
what these people are doing
what the the d.a and the courts and this
corrupt justice system they they think
they're being compassionate or at least
they say they're being compassionate oh
these poor criminals we have to feel bad
for the criminals ignore the victims
ignore the guys getting pushed around
and threatened and attacked we just have
to feel really bad i gosh can you
imagine how society must have failed
what's his name austin simon ah that
darn society
making him commit at least eight prior
crimes and then attack this bodega guy
and then and then in an act of
self-defense the bodega guy stabs him
because austin simon played very stupid
games and got into a fight and attacked
a man over
a bag of potato chips over 75 cents
and lost his life because i do feel bad
for austin simon i don't feel bad for
him in the sense that
i don't think that this bodega guy
should be thrown in prison or charged
with any crime
bodega guy was completely completely
justified i feel bad for austin simon
because he's an idiot and i feel bad for
austin simon because of the way that i
feel bad for all criminals they've gone
down a bad path they are harming not
only society but they're harming
themselves socrates wrote about this or
well
plato wrote about this in the voice of
socrates that we really should pity
criminals because they're harming
themselves as they injure other people
they're really injuring themselves
they're injuring their own souls
and then this guy winds up dead in a
bodega
because he played stupid games and he
had to win stupid prizes furthermore
though
if this d.a
if this court if this criminal justice
system
were tougher on criminals
fewer austin simons would end up dead if
this guy austin simon didn't think that
he could just walk into a bodega and
because of political correctness and
because of intersectionality and because
of soft on crime policies he could just
do whatever he wants steal whatever he
wants push whoever he wants around and
nothing's going to happen and if if
anyone tries to arrest him the cop is
going to be the one who gets lambasted
in the media not the criminal if he
didn't think that he could go in there
and harm people and commit crimes with
impunity
he'd be less likely to do it and he'd be
less likely to end up dead
it's not compatible i think
we would have a much safer society and
we would have many fewer needless deaths
if there were more jose alba's in the
world
stabbing people when they are attacked
they're good on jose alba the guy not
only should not be arrested not only
should not be charged with a crime the
guy should be given a medal for public
service because not only did he defend
himself which is his right
but he is sending a message to other
criminals don't do it don't do it guys
it's not worth it it's not worth it for
the bag of potato chips or the candy bar
or the bottle of soda or the 75 cents
your life even your life even you
degenerate criminals who are
wreaking havoc on society even your
lives your mostly miserable lives are
worth more than 75 cents
but unfortunately
that's not what the what the authorities
are doing the authorities are
encouraging more stupid games you play
stupid games you win stupid prizes i'm
going to play you two clips back to back
from lori lightfoot the eccentric mayor
of chicago lori lightfoot is very upset
over the intense harsh toxic political
rhetoric so i'm going to tell you what
she said a few days ago
and then what she said a couple weeks
before that
the toxicity
in our public discourse is a thing that
i think we should all be concerned about
right and it's ironic obviously that
we're having this conversation and what
happened on independence day you know
we're not like a lot of other countries
where
the independence their version of
independence day is marked with you know
troops and tanks and no what we do in
the united states is we come together as
a community
if you write clarence thomas concurrence
he said thank you
clarence thomas
[Applause]
so i guess we had to bleep it out but
she says f clarence thomas f him and
that's and we need less toxic rhetoric
we need to cool down the rhetoric you
effing clarence thomas nazi racist uh
evil you well hey guess what if you want
less toxic discourse
you're you're probably going to need to
engage in less toxic discourse and you
don't want to do that you're obviously
being disingenuous when you complain
about the discourse so that's fine but
just know
when you do it when you play those
stupid games you will get you will in
fact get
stupid prizes
speaking of very important matters
matters of life and death even you've
got to go check out epic will
right now go to
epicwill.com use promo code knowles did
you know this is an interesting fact did
you know that 100 of people who skydive
will die
did you know that also 100 of people who
breathe will die it's going to happen no
one here gets out alive man not not on
this earth not in this world okay so
whether you're gonna jump out of an
airplane at fifteen thousand feet or
you're just gonna go quietly in your
sleep either way you're gonna need a
will all right best way to get a will go
to epic will right now your will is not
about you your will is about your loved
ones and the very difficult decisions
that they will face
if and when something happens to you
decisions such as whether to keep you on
life support or not whether to bury you
or cremate you if you are a parent you
definitely don't want a judge deciding
who should step in and raise your kids
just some bureaucrat comes in and says
okay your kid's going to be raised by
so-and-so no don't do that go to
epicwill.com use promo code no save 10
on epic will's complete will package
epic will can set you up with a will in
as little as five minutes super easy
well worth 119 to secure your family's
future no matter where you're at in life
14 000 feet in the air or right here on
the ground you need to have a will go to
epicwheel.com use promo code knowles
today
speaking of life and death really really
shocking sad story out of japan this is
just breaking now the former prime
minister shinzo abe has been
assassinated
a young man he was only 67 years old i
believe he was assassinated by
some unknown guy
they've arrested the guy who killed him
but guy was about 41 years old i think
shinzo abe was campaigning for other
candidates obviously he wasn't
campaigning himself because he's out of
office and what makes it especially
weird well two things make it especially
weird one japan has extremely strict gun
control and abe was assassinated with a
gun
seems like some sort of makeshift type
of gun but obviously it was effective
two shots fired one of which appears to
abe's heart and he died
almost immediately he died he died it
was
shot last night and then by this morning
the news had broken
that that was very strange and then i i
think the other reason why this is
sending shock waves throughout the world
is because abe is a form was a former
prime minister
it would actually be less weird if abe
were assassinated while he was in office
that would seem to make more sense he's
got power he might be doing things that
other people disapprove of and so some
extremely angry aggressive activist or
just or some lunatic would go out and
and assassinate him
why would you assassinate a former
prime minister it's really scary because
it makes you feel that nobody is safe i
obviously don't follow japanese politics
all that closely but ave appears to have
been extremely popular a very good prime
minister of japan longest-serving prime
minister of japan he
was a nationalist he looked out for
japan's interests that's probably why he
and donald trump got along so well and
they did appear to strike up a
friendship they went golfing together
one of my absolute favorite moments from
the trump administration
was when he went to visit shinzo abe and
then there was a major worldwide
international scandal because trump
fed the koi fish and he
the media said he poured too much food
into the koi fish pond even though i
don't think he did anyway it's uh it's
very sad because he was he was a good
ally for trump uh during the
administration a good uh
good responsible leader and uh treated
the united states rather well and it's
that's very sad to see i have very
little more to say on it other than
other than what it means beyond japan
and what it means beyond abe and what it
means for all of us at a time where
we're facing such political uncertainty
and we feel like the the institutions
are losing our trust in the world order
is spiraling out of control it is
especially scary that a prime minister
would be assassinated and it's even more
especially scary that a pro that a
former prime minister would be
assassinated because it makes one feel
really no one is safe
really opens up a huge number of people
who could be who could be in danger
speaking of strange events
happening
with shadowy cabals and assassins and
secret societies and all sorts of
nefarious conspiracies do you know about
the georgia guidestones have you ever
heard about the georgia guidestones i
had heard about them
but until just a couple of days ago i
had kind of forgotten about them because
the georgia guidestones are this bizarre
stonehenge structure that was erected in
the late 1970s in georgia and no one
really knows who was behind it and then
a couple of days ago they got blown up
and we don't know who blew them up
so it this was erected in 1979
and the reason people are are interested
in the georgia guidestones is because it
seems kind of
occult
seems kind of conspiratorial
new world ordery there are a lot of
conspiracies surrounding them or
conspiracy theories quote-unquote
probably conspiracies too in in june
a guy using the pseudonym robert c
christian
approached the elberton granite
finishing company
anonymously or pseudonymously and he
said that a small group of loyal
americans wanted to erect this structure
and so the the granite company said okay
and they gave him a ridiculously high
number for the cost because they thought
it was bizarre and they didn't want to
do it and then the secret society said
okay that's fine
that's fine don't worry that cost is
fine and then they went out and bought a
bunch of land and they erected this
bizarre stonehenge-like structure on
there and they had
10 commandments on there but they're not
the normal ten commandments they're not
the christian ten commandments
they were kind of
anti-anti-commandments
here's what they said first one
maintain humanity under 500 million in
perpetual balance with nature 500
million how many people do we have right
now
8 billion or something maybe more
maintain 500 million that means you'd
have to eradicate the vast majority of
the world population
guide reproduction wisely improving
fitness and diversity so that's just
eugenics that just means kill off the
weak
kill off the the inferior races and make
sure you improve the fitness of the race
unite humanity with a living new
language that's some weird babylon kind
of stuff rule passion faith tradition
and all things with tempered reason
it sounds like kind of weird
enlightenment secret society kind of
talk we need to subdue faith and passion
and tradition with our reason with our
age of enlightenment reason
protect people and nations with fair
laws and just core it's okay i support
that that sounds good
let all nations rule internally
resolving external disputes in a world
court
okay i'm halfway on board with that i
like ruling internally and i like some
diplomacy but what is this world court
are we talking about a kind of one-world
government here avoid petty laws and
useless officials yep sounds good to me
balanced personal rights with social
duties okay prize truth beauty love
seeking harmony with the infinite
so i yeah okay that's fine i get the
first part's definitely fine what this
language though of the infamous it
sounds
it sounds like the weird esoteric
language of those secret societies that
cropped up during the enlightenment and
that have wreaked a lot of havoc on
civilization and then be not a cancer on
the earth leave room for nature
leave room
for nature
be not a cancer on the earth well that
sounds like what the left believes the
left believes that human beings are a
kind of a cancer that's why they're so
worried about overpopulation like these
people are they're so worried about our
horrible effect killing the environment
we humans we're the problem we're the
disease
we must we must return to nature and
allow nature to heal by killing
ourselves and not having any kids
it's weird it's creepy it's
it has the language of secret societies
and new age cults and all sorts of stuff
that i don't like
the georgia guidestones were bad
i am glad that they are gone
i don't know how they were destroyed was
it someone affiliated with the stones
that destroyed them i guess probably not
was an act of vandalism there have been
acts of vandalism there before i don't i
don't support breaking the law but i'm
glad they're gone they're bad monuments
they
speak to a false religion and i'm glad
that they're no longer there okay and
that's as simple as that
it's bad stuff i was reminded i was
reading last night hillary bellock and
he he was such a clear thinker he was a
historian uh he was a catholic writer he
wrote a lot about religion
he just reminds me and and this is
something that we've got to remind
ourselves pretty regularly
the fundamental
distinction
among all the people of the world is not
race it's really not yes races have
differences and
different cultures and different
geographies but that's not the
fundamental distinction the fundamental
distinction among human beings is not
even sex men and women are totally
different they're complementary but
that's not really what separates us
it's religion it's not nationality it's
not politics it's not it's it's religion
ultimately because religion
even if you don't think you're religious
even if you don't go to church even if
you don't think that you're practicing
rituals
you are everything comes out of religion
because any way you act in the world
you've got to have some sense of what is
right and wrong and what is true and who
you are and what your place is in the
world and what we're all here for and
what you're even doing and what you even
want all of that ultimately has to come
from religion politics is not going to
suffice science is not going to suffice
those are all category errors okay
they're not going to answer the biggest
questions only religion can do that
and it's it's very bad
when
we when our religious monuments every
every society has religious monuments
there is has never ever been in all of
human history a total separation between
religion and the state can't happen
it's very bad when our public religious
symbols are
false and wrong and
lead to destruction we have religious
symbols all over our society we just
don't totally recognize them as such the
rainbow flag is a religious symbol that
makes totally moral claim well immoral
claims but it may but it's making claims
about morality the georgia guidestones
are
are religious symbols
more explicitly religious symbols there
have been
secret societies in american history
that have wreaked a great great deal of
brought a great deal of havoc there was
even at one point in america there was
an anti-mason party that's how prominent
the secret societies were okay and
people will call you a conspiracy
theorist when you point out hey these
georgia guidestones are kind of weird
well
it's it's not some random theory it's
not a tinfoil hat somebody put them up
these these sorts of movements and
esoteric societies they do exist they do
believe things they are pushing an
agenda some are less hidden than others
some are right out there in public
that's not a conspiracy theory that's a
conspiracy
and
when conspiracies are are allowed to
flourish and they're against the
national interest it's good when they
get stopped okay that's i'm not going to
complain that the creepy weird cult
guide stones
were taken down
speaking of population control
there's a story that nobody is reporting
on but this is shocking stuff so
big pro-life win we've the supreme court
just overruled roe v wade and planned
parenthood bkc great great new pro-life
laws because the issue has been returned
to the states
but your taxpayer dollars are still
going to fund abortion you everyone in
this country
every american listening to this show
right now is funding abortion
because joe biden is taking your
taxpayer dollars
and using it to transport illegal aliens
and specifically illegal alien miners
out of texas to other states
to kill their children to go get
abortions
this news just broke
many federal shelters for unaccompanied
children
that have been caught at the u.s mexico
border
are now flying or driving
people using federal funds these young
people to other states for abortions and
it didn't just start they've been doing
it for nine months ever since pro-life
laws
started to go into effect according to
the aclu which supports the
infanticide they say time is really of
the essence when someone needs access to
abortion
that's brigitte amiri who's the deputy
director of the aclu's reproductive
freedom project
listen to that ghoulish sentence
time is really of the essence when
someone needs access to an abortion
why
why is time of the essence
is it because
abortion will be outlawed after a
certain number of weeks as it is
everywhere in the world really except
for parts of the united states and china
and canada and north korea
is that why well but if you're already
transporting the illegal aliens out of
texas to other states you just take them
to a state like oregon where there are
no limits on abortion at all you can
take them to a state like new york where
there are no limits on abortion at all
so why is time of the essence
because beyond the laws time is of the
essence because at a certain point
people realize it's a baby
and
the young people are not going to want
to kill their babies generally speaking
at
25 weeks 26 it's just so obviously a
baby that when you feel the kicks
constantly you can see the baby so
clearly on the ultrasound
that's why time is we got to kill the
babies before people realize their
babies that's what they're saying
this
this administration is so
fanatically pro-abortion
so fanatically pro-abortion they are
spending money
to
take
young people minors who by the way
frequently are brought to get abortions
to cover up sexual assault
right when when an adult
rapes a minor
the way to cover up the crime is to go
have the minor get an abortion so so
that's heinous enough as it is now now
you're paying for it and now joe biden
is pushing this kind of thing
it's not this is not about a choice this
is not about a reasonable disagreement
on when a human life
takes on value
this has become a sacrament for the left
look no further than elizabeth warren
elizabeth warren i think when you look
into her eyes you can see most clearly
the the demonic nature of abortion when
when the supreme court opinion was
leaked in dobbs she gave that press
conference where she was walking from
the capitol and
the woman had the fire of a thousand
sons in a rush where this is terrible
and we're gonna fight this
i have a plan to kill more maybe then it
was super spooky man it was something
like you'd read in the new testament of
people possessed or obsessed by demons
so elizabeth warren there's another clip
that just came out of her from some time
ago though it's getting a lot more play
right now where elizabeth warren says
it's not enough that we have legal
abortion it's not enough that we
encourage people to kill their babies
it's not enough that we fund planned
parenthood the abortion mill now we've
got to go further we've got to shut down
crisis pregnancy centers that don't kill
babies
here in massachusetts
these so-called
crisis pregnancy centers
outnumber
genuine abortion clinics by
three to one she says women walk into
the centers believing they'll get
abortions instead they try to talk women
out of it she calls it a bait and switch
they are giving it over to people who
wish them harm and that has to stop we
need to put a stop to that in
massachusetts right now
who wish them harm the crisis pregnancy
centers
which
offer usually free services very very
low cost services to pregnant women in
distress
and who promise to take care of the
women and their
babies they're doing women harm
how because elizabeth warren says if the
center won't kill the woman's child
that constitutes harm killing a baby
is charitable
not killing the baby and taking care of
the mother and the baby that's harm
we've got it's not enough
just to even support abortion
you've got to oppose pro-life it just it
just
goes to show you that all this language
of pro-choice has has always been a
ridiculous lie and i really would
encourage we've talked at the top of the
show about not squishing i really
encourage conservatives never to use
that phrase pro-choice it's so
ridiculous
it's so euphemistic
i i'm willing to use the left's language
in certain instances
but i'm not willing to lie for the left
pro-choice
is a ridiculous it doesn't tell you
anything about it if an alien from outer
space heard the phrase pro-choice they
would have no idea what what the person
was talking about
it's intentionally deceptive so i
wouldn't use that language and and by
the way even if you did use that
language they're not talking about a
choice they want to shut down the crisis
pregnancy centers they want to stop you
from having the choice to have your baby
they want to
lower the population of the world they
want to support the georgia guidestones
they want to
limit the horrible effects of human
beings the cancer on the earth on the
environment and on society they want to
practice eugenics they've been open
about this this isn't some tinfoil hat
conspiracy theory planned parenthood was
founded as a eugenics organization okay
they they tell it to you they tell it
right to your face all right
and we should take it seriously we
should take it seriously one because
it's a serious problem but two because
our vice president insists that we need
to take things seriously because of as
seriously we need to take things
we gotta take this stuff seriously as
seriously as you are because you have
been forced to have to take it seriously
the whole nation should understand
and have a level of empathy
to understand that this can happen
anywhere
in any peace loving community
and we should stand together
and speak out
about why it does stop
and what this seriously reminds us is
joe biden's greatest advantage going
right now which is everything is going
very poorly you're seeing the
consequences of playing stupid games in
society which is winning stupid prizes
on the economy on crime on immigration
on foreign affairs on everything bad
ideas bad policies have bad consequences
and yet this guy who can barely speak
who clearly has lost a step or a hundred
steps this guy
is probably still going to be able to
keep the democrat nomination in 2024 or
at least he has a very good shot at it
because all the people around him are
even worse he's made one really smart
move it's a really smart stupid move
which is he has surrounded himself with
people who are somehow less competent
and less likable than himself there has
been a lot of excitement about daily
wire plus and also also a lot of
questions what is daily wire plus how is
it different from the daily wire how do
i access it what does it cost what is
the purpose of life what is the airspeed
velocity of an unladen swallow daily
wire plus is everything you love about
the daily wire all under one umbrella
podcasts plus content from jordan
peterson including his archives and his
new content plus the prageru library
plus movies and documentaries
plus kids content which is coming soon
in other words
this is our ever expanding multimedia
universe you access it by going to
dailywireplus.com
or you download and open the daily wire
app then you click or tap where it says
watch boom you're there good news is if
you were already a daily wire member you
are now a daily wire plus member for the
same great price if you are not yet a
member the good news is that right now
if you go to dailywireplus.com you get
35 off your new membership help us build
the future
you want to see become a
dailywireplus.com
member today we'll be right back with a
lot more
welcome back to the show it is now my
favorite time of the week that i've been
longing for all week it is the mailbag
specifically the voicemail bag sponsored
by puretalk go to puretalk.com select a
plan enter promo code noel's podcast to
save 50 off your first month you'll have
a great cell phone plan you'll save a
bunch of money and you will keep the
voicemail bag on this show
first question up
hey michael steven here my best friend
has a doctorate in english and spent
much of his education studying feminism
and gender theory so he maintains that
gender is a purely social construct that
is in no way informed by biological sex
i attempted to argue the idea that a
majority of men or women would inform
the idea of the genders at a base level
and he denied that stating that there is
no individual aspect of either
masculinity or femininity that holds up
under concentrated scrutiny for example
women are more likely to desire to be
the primary child care provider is not
something he'd agree with because he'd
say that there's no objective way to
prove that this is true from a
biological standpoint as opposed to
cultural influence
just because a majority conforms to
those characteristics or believes they
exist doesn't mean that they are rooted
in reality he points to supposedly
gender-based concepts throughout history
that have been proven false like the
belief that women are less intelligent
than men as evidence that my
argumentation methodology is flawed and
that because it's based in the concept
of the majority it doesn't hold up to
his
counter-arguments i know that he would
welcome a compelling and intellectually
sound rebuttal even though i don't think
he would change his mind
so what argument would you make to
counter his and to reinforce what is to
me and likely you the obvious truth
love your show and the work you do
thank you very much the problem with
debunking his argument is that he isn't
making an argument he's just saying a
thing
he's just saying sex and gender are
different
you say okay well how's that he said
well because they just are
well okay what's the difference now
for the last 50 years or so of the sex
gender distinction on the left they say
that gender is cultural and social
sex is biological because of the
transgender movement they've started to
switch that a little bit now so they'll
say things like one can have a
biologically female penis so they're
they're saying that gender actually is
biological or transgenderism for
instance is when a person's brain has
the gender that is female but the their
physical biology is male but of course
your brain is physical so that that
stuff doesn't make a lot of sense i
guess i would begin to his point on the
idea that women are less intelligent
i've never thought women are less
intelligent than men i think women can
be extremely clever though ironically he
makes this point that there's no study
or rather that even this has been
debunked but larry summers got thrown
out of harvard the president of harvard
university got thrown out because he
conducted a study and suggested that the
iq bell curve for women is smaller than
the iq bell curve for men which doesn't
mean that women are just stupider than
men or something it actually means women
are at the at the very very highest
extremes of intelligence are slightly
less intelligent but also slightly
smarter than men at the two extremes so
again i don't particularly care about
larry summers or his study and i think
all studies are basically fake but even
if if he is solely relying on studies
they don't seem to prove his point
regardless i just think it's so
silly the place he's beginning from
because he's saying
he's saying look
we've got
the entire body of human knowledge for
all of human history which says that men
and women are different and act
differently and men are from mars and
women are from venus and every single
culture in all of human history has
known this not just the men but the
women have known this everywhere
but
i want to study
so but what about my studies or
something like that and it's just so
silly you begin with this question are
men and women different
yes we can see that men and women are
different
does the physical world say
does our physical reality
say something about what we should do
with our physical reality to say does
our body say something about what we
should do with our body then this is
clearest when it comes to sex right men
have a role in sex and women have a role
in sex and the consequence of that is
that the women become pregnant and grow
a child in their wombs men can't do that
women can do that
does that means men and women are
different does the fact of becoming
pregnant say something about how women
ought to behave and how they do behave
when they become pregnant that is
different from men
yes that is obviously true
do men naturally take on
different roles because of this because
we've got this undeniable fact of
different sexual slash gender roles when
it comes to pregnancy and sex so does
this does this occur in other aspects of
life
yes this is obviously true you look at
the oldest hunter-gatherer tribes men
and women have different roles you look
at tribes that still live in a more
primitive way around the world today
there are different roles for men and
women when walsh went to africa for his
documentary he asked what is a woman to
the african tribe and both the men and
women gave the same answer it's very
interesting answer they said
the men are the people who do the role
of the men
and the women are the people who do the
role of the women that it begins not
with some
shallow kind of discourse on even
biology or something but with duty with
role with with a place in society
you could point out that in politics
we're not just individuals free-floating
atoms on our own but man is essentially
a political animal a social being that
has identity in his role in society
and men and women
have different roles that happens
naturally and even when social reformers
really want to mess with that people
still go out and do it this is why when
betty friedan was debating simone de
bevoir two feminists
in the late 20th century they were
debating what feminism should look like
betty friedan said women should have a
choice they can either take on the
traditional role of women and raise
children and take care of the family in
home economics or they should be allowed
to go out and work and and not take care
of their family
and
simone dubois said no
no they should not be given that choice
betty frdance what do you mean why
shouldn't they be given that choice and
simone de beauvoir said something very
revealing she said if women are given
the choice to raise their kids they will
and we can't have that that's not
conducive to liberation women will take
on their natural roles 99 times out of
100 and we can't have that that's not
good for feminism so those are those are
just a smattering of points i would make
to debunk the argument that he is not
making okay next question
hey michael uh love the show i've been
listening to it for a couple years now
and i share it with friends and family
uh just wanted to ask i'm an artist and
having having worked for disney you know
very briefly in my career um
i i'm just so disappointed with
everything that they're doing now
and i'm just asking a question in
regards to
content creation for social i sometimes
wonder should i create art that exposes
um
the just the demonic
uh reality of what they are and what
they what they've been doing lately or
do i just create art uh that's good
that's wholesome
and that shows the light of jesus um not
so much on the nose but you know a
little bit more creative i just often
wonder what type of content should i be
creating as an artist sometimes i wonder
do people want to view art to try to get
away from everything that's going on or
should art be some sort of a voice and i
often find myself struggling between
those two approaches
i don't really see the distinction
because if i think of art like jeremias
bosh's garden of earthly delights
it's both very scary and you know
demonic and really awful but it's also
extremely beautiful or i think of
caravaggio probably my favorite artist i
have a caravaggio
uh print it's not an original hanging in
my office
but caravaggio has all sorts of
extremely intense very
scary even
paintings but they're extremely
beautiful
even the paintings of
you know
john the baptist's head
or or a gustav de rey's depictions of
dante's inferno
those are scary and even depictions of
hell but they
in turn do depict something that is
ultimately beautiful and they do convey
the light of christ
if only by contrast if only by showing
you how horrible hell is and how we
ought to avoid hell so
i i don't
i don't think it's
i i don't think beauty and sublimity are
necessarily require you to paint you
know thomas kincaid a fire in every
window and and smoke coming out of every
chimney i don't think you need to
produce kitsch or schmaltzy kind of art
uh but it it should it should be to an
end i i would encourage you not to paint
ugly hideous absurd things
you shouldn't go down the da da path for
instance you shouldn't do that
because that that can be not edifying
but degenerating and so i i certainly
wouldn't recommend that and then to your
point on political art
your art shouldn't be shallow
all art is political in the sense that
it describes aspects of the world that
we live in and
gives us some perspective from our own
role in the world which is social so
it's all political in that sense but it
doesn't need to be agit prop you know it
doesn't need to be really shallow
ideological kind of art do this didactic
pedantic nonsense you know i wouldn't
recommend that either i would make it
beautiful and if you ground it in the
truth that beauty can come from scenes
that are of the glories of heaven you
know from paradise or they can be scenes
from hell and both both will be
edifying as works of art all right next
one
mr knowles thank you for taking my
question and thank you puretalk for
making it possible
in the aftermath of the overturning of
roe secular women everywhere have
threatened chastity and an end to hookup
culture
if you can even imagine such a world you
know this would render apps like tinder
bumble and the like obsolete
we are all excited about what the daily
wire is doing not only to rebut
left-wing pop culture but give the right
a pop culture all its own
my question is this
is it time for the daily wire to start a
conservative dating app
my name ideas include swipe right with a
capital r
the d wire or my favorite maga matches
with an optional paid upgrade to ultra
mega matches
i do expect royalties what do you think
you deserve royalties you probably won't
get them but you deserve royalties for
that
i i love the idea because i want more of
you people write in all the time you're
single you want to meet people but you
don't want to date some squishy libs so
you don't know what to do and you you
know i think it would be great it'd be a
wonderful thing if we could set up
our wonderful daily wire members and
listeners
but there is a structural problem and
you alluded to it in the first part of
your question which is
dating apps have an incentive to keep
people dating
they don't have an incentive to get
people married
and the only way they have an incentive
to get people married is in as much as
people who want to get married will sign
up for the app to then
ideally get married so it has a kind of
attraction in that way but if you want
consistent customers then you need
people to stay on the apps which means
you've got to discourage marriage and
encourage the hookup culture
so it would be a very difficult needle
to thread i'm not saying it would be
impossible but it would be
it would very likely become
self-undermining if you had a
conservative dating app that was
strictly meant for marriage unless you
could incentivize the company to
incentivize people to get married i
don't know maybe you have to pay a dowry
to the company if you get married or
something like that we'll have to look
into it then we can use part of those
dowries to pay you your your royalties
next question
hey michael love the show anyways um
i am a high school student who has
always been conservative but i'm
starting to uh
i'm sort of converting to christianity
at the moment
um anyways
um
i love math i've always been much more
talented at math
than uh
than english like i actually struggled
with english when i was a kid but i've
been always
off the charts in math got a perfect
score on the act and sat math sections
and um
i've been looking into like careers i
could go into
and in terms of applying math
and turning my own personal crank
artificial intelligence and machine
learning sounds very interesting to me
but also i do have a few ethical
concerns about that so
i was wondering what you think
thanks love your show
really good question the smartest people
i know
almost all of the smartest people i know
are
working in some way on these sorts of
issues
the
uh a really good friend of mine from
college who's a super intelligent
brilliant mathematician brilliant
physicist
he's working on ai and i think it's cool
he i just saw him at a reunion and he
was showing me all the crazy stuff that
they're doing
the art that these machines are making
the poems that the machines are writing
it's super scary
i i wouldn't have ethical question
questions rather
about
the machines themselves
some people are concerned about the
ethics of what happens if the machine
becomes conscious the machine's not
going to become conscious it's that's
not how consciousness works so i
wouldn't worry about that you might be
concerned about the ethics of what can
be done with these machines and but this
would be similar to someone who's
working on weapons you know you might
have ethical worries about that but i i
don't think i would let that stop me
from working on it there is going to be
artificial intelligence there already is
artificial intelligence and so if you
with a your head screwed on straight and
your heart in the right place and you
know a decent sense of virtue if you are
working on it you might be able to help
influence and make sure that there are
those ethical guard rails there i think
that would be uh pretty important so go
for it plus it seems extremely cool
before we go i want to get to at least
one written mailbag question from
kristin this tuesday you brought up the
issue of antidepressants and the rise of
use after covid i was against the use of
antidepressants until i needed something
more than just talking to someone
they have improved my life greatly and i
think i would argue against your wording
of being addicted to antidepressants
they save lives and i think the issue
lies in the society my generation has to
deal with as we are more isolated than
ever
there you go what would a better
solution be
than to just stick people on
antidepressants because i would argue
that that may be the best option as of
now thank you for giving young
conservatives a voice i appreciate all
that you do really great question a lot
of people wrote in similar things to me
so i'm glad we could get to this i think
you proved my point though in your
question
because you're saying look i didn't want
to take antidepressants but then i went
on antidepressants and i felt better
yeah well that's what antidepressants do
is they chemically
uh trick you into thinking that you're
happier than you would be otherwise if
you were not on the influence of this
drug under the influence of this drug
but then you said i think the reason
that my generation is on all these
antidepressants is because our society
is so isolating i think you're totally
right about that
therefore what would the better
alternative be
if antidepressant drugs have any use at
all it will be to treat
personal psychological issues
i i think the idea of a chemical
imbalance in the brain has been pretty
discredited at this point but whatever
that phrase is trying to describe some
physical issue here that one of these
drugs could possibly address
that would at least make sense
but if the problem is not personal if
the problem is not just psychological
the problem is not just some imbalance
in your brain if the problem is as you
say social then drugs are not the answer
drugs are not the way to deal with
social problems politics is the answer
to deal with social problems at the
highest level and
and society and culture and going out
meeting people and showing up to church
on sunday and showing up to the bar
maybe to maybe restaurants or a social
club that's the way to treat it and in
the long run that's going to be a lot
better
it's it's true that for some people who
are in the throes of depression
it can be good to
give them a little bit of relief
and maybe maybe a drug can do that maybe
it can't but that can't be the long-term
solution
and often there are a lot of negative
side effects from that
it's it's just going to be tricking you
it's just going to be a lie it's going
to be numbing you like drugs do so if
you want a long-term solution
to
to put yourself back in reality then
you've got to go see people and you've
got to go interact in the real society
in fact in many ways the antidepressant
culture is not only a reaction to but
but perpetuating this culture of
isolation
in the same way that virtual reality
does because it just brings you more and
more into yourself in the same way that
transgenderism does by bringing you more
and more into your own delusions and
taking you out of objective reality and
encouraging you to just stay exactly
where you are
in a condition that for many people is
miserable so
the the solution to that and i'm not
disparaging anybody who
has taken these drugs in the past or
even is taking them now but that that
can't be
in pretty much every circumstance that
can't be your long-term solution your
long-term solution to a social problem
is to re-engage in society and that can
be scary and you might have anxiety
about it but that's just part of the
human condition we're living in such a
bizarre time does anybody else think
it's strange that we're living at a time
where we have redefined totally normal
aspects of the human condition
shame
self-doubt social anxiety the quirks
that we all have i'm so ocd that sort of
thing we've redefined all those
completely normal aspects of human life
as mental illness
and then we've redefined actual mental
illnesses like gender identity disorder
as totally normal aspects of human life
it's just completely backwards
and then when things go awry what do we
do we encourage people to isolate
themselves on the internet on media doom
scrolling popping pills that's
that's not a long-term solution
go engage in society and don't squish go
into society don't squish
wonderful to be with you as always
wonderful to hear from all of you in the
mailbag we'll see you next week
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2022.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin